one nice thing about being down in San
Diego for comic-con is sometimes we run
into friends of the show we just run
into them a couple of those friends were
nice enough to stop by tonight please
welcome from Silicon Valley Thomas
Middleditch and from Parks and
Recreation and the all-new DuckTales Ben
Schwartz
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
so hey guys good to see you hey those
are great costumes guys yeah I like that
I gotta say it is kind of cool that
you're you're cosplaying as us yeah well
you know we were a comic-con and we just
wanted to dress like our heroes I have
to say that is very very sweet they
didn't finish I'm so sorry but they were
out of Deadpool and Gandalf costume for
these and I want to give a huge shout
out to the Salvation Army on Front
Street
for me I also wanna I want to give a
personal quick shout-out to the city
morgue it it turns out when they cremate
a body they remove all the clothes and
they practically just give them away
yeah I gotta say it is impressive you
did get all the details down yeah oh
definitely we did our homework people
instantly recognize me as Andy instant
it was incredible because people were
always asking me if I was the Wendy's
girl
they did they did they didn't get the
skin tone right there I wanted to get
that just right because I think that's
very specific and quick tip okay you
know those places that do anal bleaching
right you slip on the 20 and they'll do
the whole body just a 20 just it's 120
extra bucks you get the rest of the body
and to prepare for my role as Andy I
took a ton of naps and made thorough use
of the hotel's Wi-Fi if you know what I
mean I'm talking masturbating to the
porno
[Applause]
very cool yeah we've actually been
walking around comic-con dressed like
you guys all week yeah so so so how was
it been wait what do you mean okay well
as Andy I got invited to a rooftop hotel
party hosted by none other than JJ
Abrams whoa whoa hey April
oh sorry sorry and I got to share a
pedicab with the angry bagel boss guy so
that was nice - that's a very current
reference I threw at you I hope you
enjoyed it yeah everyone was coming up
to me and telling me how much they loved
my new podcast I guess people just can't
get enough of my soothing silky boy that
sounded sexy it really yeah all right
well did you guys see any cool stuff at
Comic Con oh absolutely I got sent I got
to see the world premiere of the trailer
for the new Terminator Moon oh and two
teenagers held me down and made me watch
the new trailer for cats did you got any
panel stress and Conan unfortunately no
I was told that you Conan O'Brien have
been banned from the convention center
since 1999 for and I quote taking
pictures of Sigourney Weaver's feet yeah
okay
okay yeah all right well here's your
ring it's me
all right yeah we just got a call that
two men matching your description I just
skipped out on a $700 check at the at
the Cheesecake Factory so wait a minute
$700 at the Cheesecake Factory that's
never sir
yeah no okay wait a minute ladies and
gentlemen there's only one way to get
out of this Jam
[Music]
Thomas Middleditch Ben Schwartz
everybody